[Musique]
avant c'était toujours premier dimanche
d'octobre avec la canicule
la sécheresse le mûrissement précoce
sauf cette année bon et est un peu moins
on a avancé les vendanges service sera
le 19 septembre
[Musique]
les gamins coupe le raisin ensuite ans
il y en a un certain nombre de grappes
qui sont mis dans un fouloir il foule
avec les pieds le premier jeu est jeté
il est grave du raisin il fully presse
du raisin sous la responsabilité des
amis du procès ils boivent un peu de jus
avec les adultes pas trop et là où on
est sous l'auvent et bien il ya un
goûter offert aux enfants puis après il
ya un repas d'ensemble pour continuer la
fête
[Musique]
partagée avec les enfants surtout
du but pédagogique puis recréer toute
une filière
viticulture plantes les ceps qui
viennent de franche comté les premier
league et les derniers à replanter du
bourgogne aligoté 57